[Música]
bueno desde pequeña me tocó vivir
diferentes situaciones bastante graves
me tocó pasar por situaciones de
violencia bastante grande y adicciones a
mi alrededor y cuando digo violencia no
solamente me refiero a la violencia
física que es la que piensa la mayoría
de las personas cuando uno dice esa
palabra
la violencia psicológica también pasó
por mi vida y desde bien chiquitita y es
una de las que más duele a veces la
adicciones no solamente van de la mano
con las drogas va mucho más allá de eso
y también son bastante graves y quiero
que también lo tengan claro desde ahora
a pesar de todas estas adversidades
seguir creciendo en este entorno
bastante duro pero tratando de rescatar
siempre lo mejor y siempre tratando de
ayudar una mano amiga que estuviera al
lado y necesitara ayuda de alguien
porque quizás cuando yo necesite esa
ayuda
nadie me la dio o eso era lo que yo
pensaba en ese momento porque me quería
hacer sentir a mí misma que estaba sola
y estaba bastante equivocada
seguí creciendo y es en carne
desencadene diferentes tipos de
depresiones
y avanzaba en una y la terminaba y me
sentía bien y avanzaba en otra y la
terminada y me volvía a sentir bien y
las depresiones iban y venían en mi vida
y yo sabía que eso no estaba bien para
una niña
a lo largo de la vida uno tiende a tener
muchas piedras en el zapato mucho
obstáculo en el camino
muchos problemas bastante grande
pero en todas las personas hay problemas
diferentes y nadie vive su vida de la
misma manera ni nadie lo enfrenta igual
algunos quizás se le enfrenta un
problema delante y dicen ok voy a luchar
para poder superar esto voy a salir
adelante otras personas se quedan en sus
piezas sin hacer nada
días semanas meses
yo quise en ese momento la noche
me quedé sin hacer nada
solamente ayudando a pequeñas manos
amigas alrededor que lo necesitaba
es difícil ponerme a pensar este tema de
los patrones
cuando era un poquitito más chica o
hasta el día de hoy me toca a veces
salir a la calle con hombres de mi
familia
y en una cuadra aquí vamos caminando
pasaba a otro hombre más adelante que no
conocía muy me silbaba me gritaba algo
el típico mijita rica que te gritan en
la calle aunque sea ya una niña chica
difícil y ellos que decían está mal se
enojaba en eso no se puede hacer pero un
par de cuadras más adelante pasado a
otra niña y ella o sea es lo mismo pero
esa niña
porque está mal cuando otro lo hace pero
no cuando yo lo hago
porque a veces miramos más lo mal que
hace otra persona o lo bien que hacen
las cosas las otras personas y no los
bien o mal que lo estamos haciendo
nosotros
porque lo hacemos porque tendemos a
fijarnos mucho más en que otra persona
se siente orgullosa de nosotros y no
nosotros mismos porque tendemos a creer
que solamente nos podremos amar a
nosotros mismos cuando otra persona lo
haga antes no no es así
y bueno todo básico cuando estaba con
esta depresión bastante grande la
depresión más grande que tuve
y al baño o vomitar porque me sentía
gorda horrible
y en la casa me frenaba y mention que
estaba mal y yo no entendía no lo creía
me seguía sintiendo mal en el colegio me
seguían haciendo bullying
y nadie me ayudaba y vamos a reclamar y
nadie estaba ahí
nadie nos quería ayudar
nos decían que si nosotros le contábamos
a alguien mal problemas y agrandar y
hasta el día de hoy lo siguen haciendo
con diferentes situaciones y diferentes
personas
y es difícil querer pedir ayuda y que no
te la den
llegaron las elecciones del centro de
estudiantes antes de las elecciones
siempre hacen un taller de liderazgo
llegamos a ese momento el taller de
liderazgo
y me sentía solo en el colegio sin tanto
amigos sin tanta cosa no me gustaba ir
al colegio no me gustaba estar en la
casa pero llegado a ese momento llegamos
ese taller
pasó una semana y me ofrecieron
postularme en la lista con ellos me
dijeron queremos que esté ahí con
nosotros que te postulé a la lista del
centro estudiante con nosotros porque
sabemos que con un potencial como el
tuyo también podemos ganar porque
tenemos muchas personas muy potentes
aquí
dije que si llega a mi casa no sabía lo
que estaba haciendo y le conté a mi
familia y como que no se sentían tan
orgulloso porque en realidad era como
luego de eso pasó el tiempo siguieron el
tema de las elecciones que los
cartelitos por acá las guerras por allá
ganamos ganamos las elecciones del
centro de estudiantes avanzó el año y ya
me da lo mismo si llegaba no llegaba a
la casa me daba igual se había no no
había un problema en la casa me daba
igual se habían gritos o golpes
y me da igual si mejor es que me
molestaban que más nada decía yo estoy
haciendo algo bueno y no sólo por mí
sino que por el resto
y descubrí
que ayudará al resto vacacionaba y
ayudar al resto me hacía sentir viva
y me hacía sentir que estaba haciendo
algo bien por fin y no sólo por mí
sino que no solamente me podía ayudar a
amigo todo lo que yo tenía que no era
así de chiquitita como me hicieron
sentir tanto tiempo que podía lograr
algo más
cuál es la lástima de todo esto que tuve
que esperar a que otras personas se
sintieran orgullosa de mí
para poder empezar a quererme más
dónde está el amor propio dónde está el
cariño que nos tenemos que tener dónde
está el primero tu segundo twitter cero
tú que me decía mi abuela
no lo encontraba
termina ese año primer año en el centro
de estudiantes como delegadas ganamos
muchos proyectos nos felicitaron por
todos lados perfectos este otro año nos
vamos con todos llegamos al otro año
postulaciones de nuevo me postulé como
presidente del centro de estudiantes
ganamos
si yo el año y me daba lo mismo si es
que llegaba a la casa y estaban gritando
y me daba lo mismo sí que llegaba a la
casa y pasaba algo yo salí a reuniones
de lo lindo
pero pasa en reunión en el proyecto
dándome cuenta que habían un montón de
jóvenes con vidas difíciles en comunas
difíciles
que salían adelante
y no hacían dando encuestas con unos
casos bastante especiales hay niños que
tienen enfermedades terminales bastante
grandes y están ahí y siguen luchando
por sus días día a día y viven el día a
día lo viven como si no hubiera un
mañana y lo disfrutan y nosotros que
estamos bien
no sabemos disfrutarlo y no sabemos
agradecer lo que tenemos y si yo en ese
momento me sentí sola
no lo estaba
nunca estuve yo me sentí sola porque yo
me estaba sintiendo así porque yo no
quería abrir los ojos porque yo no me
quería quitar esa venda de la cabeza
porque yo no quería llegar y decir
soy buena tengo voz no necesito que
otras personas me representen porque yo
me puedo representar a mí misma y me
puedo querer a mí antes de que otra
persona me quiera
terminó el año y nos ganamos un premio
por ser uno de los mejores centros de
estudiantes y toda la felicidad pero
resulta que llegó al principio del año
pasado nos postulamos de nuevo no
ganamos
y hubieron muchas tradiciones entre
medio
y el colegio nos motivó a comernos como
si fueran un par de caníbales a
pelearnos entre nosotros y hacer estos
tipos de competencia en eeuu como si
tuviéramos que andar vendiendo
pastelitos en el recreo porque la gente
votara por nosotros en centros
estudiantes no era eso es tratar de
hacer la voz de un colegio entero de
estudiantes que tienen problemáticas de
estudiantes que tienen dudas que quizás
ni siquiera nosotros podemos resolver
pero podemos ir con alguien más ya que
si tiene la respuesta y hacerla llegar
de una manera mucho más fácil y el
colegio no nos quiso enseñar eso en ese
momento
desencadenó una nueva depresión en mi
volvía a llegar con pena la casa volvió
a llegar con rabia volví a sentir que no
podía valer nada
y los problemas seguían aumentando
seguían aumentando y me volví a ver
abrumada por toda esta cantidad de
dramas a mi alrededor está terminando el
año y una mi amiga me mandó un mensaje
al teléfono y me dice oye quieren hacer
un grupo para hablar de feminismo yo
dije cómo van a hablar de feminismo si
en el colegio no se habló de feminismo
de mole
y encima el grupo y la primera actividad
que hicimos como grupo
fue sentarnos en un círculo
y que levantáramos la mano según las
preguntas que vamos haciendo
y en este momento le voy a hacer las
mismas preguntas a ustedes quiero que
levanten la mano
que levante la mano a la persona que ha
visto violencia alguna vez
que levante la mano la persona que ha
sufrido violencia alguna vez
ejercido violencia alguna vez
en la que más cuesta pero aunque no lo
crean la mayoría hemos sido violentos
aunque no queramos admitirlo no queramos
darnos cuenta
y en ese momento hicimos lo mismo pero
la pregunta que más llego
fue cuando preguntamos que levante la
mano la persona que ha sido abusada
sexualmente alguna vez
ese día
sólo una no levantó la mano
y después en secreto
nos contó
que también había sufrido eso
nos dimos cuenta que teníamos que hacer
algo cambiar esto dejar de normalizar la
violencia en los colegios y en las casas
no estábamos dando cuenta que había
mucha información que se estaba
perdiendo entremedio que en las casas no
se hablaba de sexualidad y género en las
casas no se hablaba acerca de que la
violencia estaba mal
de que la mujer no se tenía que preparar
para llegar a cocinar a la casa
no
no nos tenemos que preparar para ser
mamá y no tenemos que aguantar que nadie
nos grite en las calles y los hombres
tampoco tienen por qué estar aguantando
esto de las mujeres solamente porque
seamos mujeres
está mal
que hicimos
apelamos el colegio con papeles y
fotografías que decían que decían esta
es la violencia intrafamiliar
esta es la violencia de pareja esta es
la violencia psicológica está la
violencia de esto ok
la gente lo rompía no olvidaba cosas no
mandar un mensaje mala por las redes
sociales que en féminas y acá que
financia el ya que ven puras mujeres
no lo típico pero el colegio nunca se
había hablado de violencia y en el
colegio nunca se habían hablado estas
temáticas porque estaban bastante
normalizadas
llegamos a ese momento terminó el año
todos querían saber de nosotros como nos
llamábamos
como nos llamamos
judas ya no somos puras mujeres ahora
también hay hombres
difícil o no todos somos feministas o no
los dos tenemos la misma religión
sin nombre
como le pusimos sin nombre nuestro
colectivo se llama sin nombre es un
colectivo juvenil social y cultural
tratamos de hacer llegar a la gente
información que no se suele dar en la
casa o en los colegios o que la prensa
mano sea
de qué manera con carteles dentro de los
colegios publicando cosas en las redes
sociales y últimamente hemos estado
bastante flujo en esa parte pero
son temas que no se hablan son temas que
dan vergüenza que no se cuentan porque
está mal contarlo porque está mal
hablarlo
no debería estar así de mal
son temas que pasan y si pasan hay que
hablarlos
siempre que hablo
le quiero hacer una invitación
porque porque a pesar de que nos
trataron mal todo este tiempo cuando
nosotros estábamos partiendo lo primero
que nosotros dijimos fue da lo mismo que
están hablando mal de nosotros están
hablando como nos dimos cuenta llegamos
a principios de este año
volvimos a hacer la misma actividad y la
gente nos rompía los carteles
pasó un día nadie lo rompió pasaron dos
días nadie nos grita da cosas y los
carteles todavía no estaban rotos
pasaron tres días y todavía los carteles
no se rompían todavía la gente no nos
escribía cosas malas por las redes
sociales ni buena ni mala pero bueno los
profesores nos felicitaban los
inspectores también el director nuevo
del colegio también nos felicitó incluso
un par de apoderados y algún otro
estudiante llegamos al final de la
semana y recién un cartel se había roto
entramos a clase y dijimos que en el
recreo lo pegamos o lo sacamos
y cuando salimos recreo hay unos niños
de segundo básico pegando los carteles
cuando nos acercamos a preguntarle por
qué lo estaban pegando nos dijeron que
eran importantes y que no debían sacarse
logramos algo logramos hacer un cambio y
en muy poco tiempo con muy pocas
personas pues la invitación que yo les
quiero hacer los quiero invitar a que se
den cuenta que los jóvenes no somos el
futuro y quiero que se quiten eso de la
cabeza no somos el futuro somos el
presente porque podemos actuar desde
ahora somos el presente para poder crear
un mejor futuro
nadie les tiene que quitar la voz que
nadie les haga creer que ustedes no
tienen voz ustedes tienen voz y voto
aquí en la quiebra el ají como dice mi
mamá y es así ok
ustedes pueden y siempre van a poder
nosotros somos jóvenes y nuestra voz se
tiene que escuchar alto y fuerte
[Aplausos]